one of the ways that chronic stress gets
under the skin to affect our health is
through affecting what we put in our
mouth so it's a very invisible
relationship to many people but when
we're stressed we mobilize a lot of
energy and we secrete this stress
hormone cortisol from our adrenal gland
and that actually stimulates our
appetite and whether we notice it or not
it actually can shape what we choose in
terms of the types of food it makes us
want more high fat sweet or salty food
something we call highly palatable food
and there's a reason why we after stress
we want more of this kind of densely
caloric food and that's because it's
good for the brain it helps calm the
brain and reduce psychological stress so
stress is kind of a double-edged sword
on the short run it can make you feel
better in the long run it can cause
problems abdominal fat diabetes heart
disease all of the problems related to
have an abdominal fat pad that type of
fat leaks into the blood so that you
have a lot of lipids in the blood so
having a big round belly is a really
good physical indicator for having a lot
of lipids or fats in the blood one of
the first steps in attacking this
relationship between stress and eating
is just asking yourself well how do you
eat under stress are you a stress eater
and remarkably people tend to know they
they know their own tendency and when we
do research on this we just simply ask
people do eat more when you're under
stress do eat less when you're under
stress and the people who eat more are
at tremendous risk of weight gain and
what we call metabolic syndrome
increases in their cholesterol and their
insulin when they're under stress so
stress for them is is more dangerous
than for the people who don't tend to go
for the donuts etc when they're under
stress so one of the things that we are
we really don't know how to tackle
stress eating and we know that people
are using it it has a functional role
they're using it to make themselves feel
better so you can't just simply take it
away you need to provide other
strategies for coping with stress so the
the one that we're testing right now is
testing whether we can teach people the
skill of mindfulness
being in the present moment can serve as
a filter to change their everyday
experience and their every their their
experience in the moment with stress so
that they're not reacting as much so
there are adrenals not secreting all
that cortisol so it can help them be
more resilient to stress on one hand we
think it because it's going to promote
stress resilience on the other hand we
think they can use it to eat more
mindfully so we're teaching people
mindful eating skills and that that can
be as simple as noticing each bite and
how it tastes and how full you feel